you talk about in the book your
friendship with Charlie Sheen I was the
only person that was going to get him
off the hit you know whatever secret
everyone else was a [ __ ] they're all
getting paid from him and so right they
wouldn't say hey get off so I would walk
in and say dude like really this it he
told you about his HIV diagnosis in 2014
right let me sit on a couch like this
and and he said he got emotional it was
actually hard he's a great guy sober and
and my and it humble but I think to get
where he needs why do you think he told
you well why did he confide in you out
of everyone because I was the only one
that it was a real friend I didn't write
I never asked him for a dime and how did
you advise him did you say to him hey
dude you've got to come clean about this
it is you didn't see and we were one
hour away from him common clean and him
getting this out before they forced him
out
they said dude you can't stop it I said
it's gonna and he's paying these people
million dollar miles ain't got people to
keep quiet yeah and I said it like I
said and by the way I mean like if they
took a poll out there and like who's the
most likely to have HIV in Hollywood I
said you know you'd win the [ __ ] land
and no one's gonna be that shocked do so
so get ahead of it he was on board and
and what happened was I think that
people all bleeding him talked him out
of it